[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance Kellyanne con job says if the
media continues to call the press
Secretary's lies lies and by extension
if it continues to call the president's
lies lies quotes we're going to have to
rethink our relationship here fine do
not interview Kellyanne con job press
secretary Spicer comes out for what is
allegedly a White House press briefing
and shouts a bitter angry statement at
the media and then refuses to take any
questions stop carrying his press
briefings live on television
Trump says the media quote are among the
most dishonest human beings on earth
right stop covering his speeches live
use a delay employ a team of fact
checkers play his rants each time he
lies stop the tape
state the facts resume the tape wait for
the next lie stop the tape again state
the facts again do not participate in
the Trump propaganda game and do not
reply to me that you are obligated to do
so because otherwise you could be
accused of dealing it amazing the
presidency because it is impossible to
deal egde it amaze something that was
never illegitimate in the first place
and do not reply to me that you must
cover these Liars because of the
marketplace of ideas or because of
commercial competition in short order
nobody who believes Trump or Conway or
Spicer or any of the other Pirates will
be watching ABC CBS NBC CNN BBC MSNBC
c-span or anything similar anyway in a
time when democracy is being rapidly
sabotage by a lunatic president and his
amoral flying monkeys like Conway and
Spicer your market and incidentally your
obligation as citizens in that bleeding
democracy your market and your
obligation are identical to identify the
lies and refute them twice as often as
they are told the hardcore Trump crowd
the fascists corporatists racists
authoritarians they're going to watch
Fox and read breitbart and watch and
read the new ones worse than Fox and
worse than Breitbart they're going to
pop up in the weeks and months to come
and there isn't F all you can do about
that
this was the exact scenario in the
bygone days when George W Bush was still
widely believed about Iraq and every
television news operation decided it was
going to wave the flag just like Fox
News or try to outdo Fox one of them put
Michael Savage on TV and every one of
them promptly got smoked in the ratings
and then some guy at MSNBC I think it
was said the Emperor is not wearing any
clothes and all of a sudden the truth
started pouring out and by the way the
hundreds of millions of dollars of
profit started pouring in the danger to
our society of for-profit journalism
especially in television has been
evident ever since the Fairness Doctrine
was eliminated and the FCC stopped
enforcing the community service and
equal time regulations that's when you
can start to begin to say as much as you
wanted on television or radio about any
controversial topic without ever being
obligated to offer Floyd our turbo two
minutes of airtime to give an editorial
reply but the blessing to our society of
for-profit journalism especially in
television has been evident ever since
the backlash against Bush a decade ago
being state-run television is profitable
being anti state-run television is
nearly as profitable to paraphrase the
immortal Bill Hicks The Gaslight Channel
oh they're going for that gas light
marketing dollar that's a good market
they're very smart
wait the anti gas light channel whoo you
know what Keith's doing now he's going
for that righteous indignation dollar
that's a big dollar a lot of people are
feeling that indignation we've done
research huge market he's doing a good
thing it would take a conscious and
conscientious decision to leave those
news consumers who believe in
administration elected on built on and
trading on nothing but lies but it is
also practice for a worse time that may
be yet to come the previous Republican
administration exploited a terrorist
attack in this country it took the
natural tendency at times of crisis of
liberals to put aside party divisions
and the natural tendency at times of
crisis of conservatives to exacerbate
party divisions
and then multiplied all that by their
Fox led Republican media echo chamber
and then they insisted on something they
branded patriotic bipartisanship but
which was in fact mono partisanship in
which they were to make all the
decisions and the role of Democrats was
to acquiesce to them or be branded
disloyal and if they are given or if
they fabricate another such crisis they
will play the same card you know
something happens about which to quote
Trump I alone can fix it thus now and
especially later there must be channels
and sites and newspapers that devote
huge swaths of their resources to
blasting back the truth towards the
Trump lies Factory it must report the
lies about health care the lies about
the release of tax returns the lies and
inevitable attempts to use the mighty
mechanisms of government against Trump's
critics it must report the truths about
broken promises to release tax returns
and falsified government statistics and
passive-aggressive influence-peddling
it must learn and it will learn how much
the Russians swung the election even if
it takes four years to learn it and how
many acts of war the Russians directed
against us and how much they had on
Trump and how much they expect him to
deliver and how many of the mainstream
Republicans will remain loyal not to the
Constitution of the United States but to
Vladimir goddamned Pugh and until all
that is found out it can simply report
all day every day that the Russian
investigation is still ongoing exactly
the way Fox News spent nearly three
years insisting that Obama's birth
certificate was still ongoing those who
own the news media especially in
television are timid types and by nature
conservative until being either of those
things threatens their investments well
fellas Trump has decided to destroy your
investments if you tell the absolute
truth he will try to bury you if you
tell his version and give airtime to his
supporters but you also have others
there to fact-check him he will still
try to bury you appease
and will produce what appeasement always
produces the victims wasting the
resources and time they should have used
defending themselves the good news of
the good news media is in fact this
little GarageBand kind of series right
here as of this one we will have done 65
commentaries under the banner of The
Closer and the resistance and as of
number 63 last week we had crossed the
threshold of 100 million views that is
an average of around a million 600,000
views per commentary and a million 600
thousand views of anything not only
suggest there's a ready audience for the
product in question whether it's
anti-trump politics or learning how to
tie your shoes an average audience of a
million six hundred thousand is larger
than the average audience at CNN or
MSNBC so remember that thing before the
election Trump TV well it is now time
for anti-trump TV and it will make
somebody at least half a billion dollars
in profits in the next four years if he
lasts for years and yet oh by the way it
also might be one of the few chances we
have to stop the United States of
America from fully descending into
fascism you know in case that still
matters to anybody resist peace